[Music]
if you think your kid's an overachiever
wait till you meet shama al-missouri
she became the minister of state for
youth affairs in the united arab
emirates at the age of 22
which made her the youngest government
minister in
the world
she was also her country's first rhodes
scholar
so i wanted to talk to shama about the
power of youth and why there aren't more
ministers of youth in more governments
what i learned that youth brings
is hope
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
you are the minister of youth for an
entire nation
and what i find so
wonderful about that is if you consider
the size of the youth population in
every nation
that most nations don't have a minister
of youth i live in the united states and
there's no minister of youth as a
cabinet position it existed in the uk
for i think a year
and then it was folded into a different
department which basically deals with
charitable giving
what was the birth what was the decision
that led to a nation deciding to have an
entire cabinet position just to
represent the youth of the nation i find
that so fascinating it's so rare in the
world that's a very good question the
ministry of youth in theory exists to
connect youth to leaders and decision
makers across all industries and sectors
and we empower youth to become the
leaders and decision makers not only for
tomorrow but for today
let's look at our region in the mena
region youth under 35 make up more than
60 percent of the population and we
believe it's very simple and nation's
ability to harness youth directly
impacts its security its gdp its global
positioning and most importantly quality
of life for every human being
and and and this ministry is based on
two fundamental beliefs youth are the
future and governments must fight must
be directly involved
and to be honest simon we can't afford
to build a future that eliminates half
of our population from contributing
their voice their talent their ideas
their energy and so one thing that's
very interesting is we don't just
involve youth
we let youth lead
and and that's maverick i think it's
it's it's the uae way we're taking very
big
risks on our biggest assets
the ministry is a design kitty startup
in every sense of the word
i want to maybe touch base on on the
point that you said it's baffling to
think of how widespread youth have been
sidelined in strategies and in
government around the world
and the significant challenge i think
is that young people are seen as
problems to manage
rather than assets to leverage and this
is a sure failing strategy for nations
in our fast-paced globalized world
it's abundantly clear what we resist
persists have you found
that by giving youth a seat at
government and their own ministry to
lead and run themselves that the
division between older generations and
younger generations have narrowed you
because you know it's always the older
generations complaining about the
younger generations and the younger
generations complaining about the older
generations is that still the case is
that human nature or because they have a
seat at the table do you find less of
that i believe that division has
narrowed so much and it narrowed because
of of the vision of government and how
it came from top down from leadership we
were just talking about how
what we resist persist and the the kind
of strategy we have in the uae is where
we nourish will flourish so if the
government resists the reality of youth
today and tomorrow they're gonna fail
their youth our global reality will be
less abundant and more dangerous place
now
on the contrary this is our strategy is
where we nourish will flourish if all
governments make changes and take risks
for you to have abundant opportunities
during this kind of precious formation
time it all comes down to how we listen
and it's communication every direction
it really sets the foundation when you
work with young people because you need
to understand them and include them one
of the subjects that i talk about more
than i think any other when somebody
says you know how do we teach leadership
and i always talk about that leadership
education lacks teaching people how to
listen empathetically and certainly one
of the things that we're struggling with
in our country
is we're so divided because both sides
refuse to listen to each other and when
i say listen meaning not hear the words
that were spoken but to try to
understand the meaning behind those
words and allow the other side to feel
heard
and we don't teach listening
we don't teach it in our schools we
don't teach it in our governments we
don't teach it in our companies and so
the fact that you're teaching listening
and you're using listening as sort of
the single most important tool to
benefit youth in the country is
it is so far ahead
i definitely hear it from companies and
government they claim they listen to
youth you know government ministers sit
around and a bunch of people talk and
they take a bunch of pictures and
then nothing
how do you build accountability
in to ensure that the stuff that they're
sharing with you
you know not all ideas are good ideas
but at least that they're heard and the
good ones actually do get shuttled
through i love this uh two weeks ago the
government approved a youth global
empowerment policy and you'd be like um
well how do you measure empowerment it's
not just a photo opportunity or a media
kind of bankrupt and so what happened
two weeks ago is the cabinet approved a
definition for youth empowerment a
measurable definition and it created a
manual and an assessment and an index
basically the youth environment manual
was what it looks like for youth to be
empowered it assesses how we're doing
against that definition that's an
assessment and it compares youth
empowerment efforts across all federal
government and that's our index and the
way we measure it is two ways one is the
government itself the the ministry every
year has to submit an entity submission
form to tell us how is it doing in terms
of the six pillars voice recognition
purpose guidance development and
opportunity the other one is we ask
young people so the young people in that
ministry and we ask them do you really
have opportunities for your development
how many of you have signed up for the
the federal government skills program
and so
this is amazing because this is exactly
the process and outcome we hope to
achieve through this manual and
assessment and this is exactly uh the
framework that will empower governments
to move forward i mean i'm sitting here
with my mouth open completely gobsmacked
i mean i've talked to people in
government many times
and
this does not sound like government
where you have metrics and you're
holding yourself accountable to these
definitions and you're reporting back on
whether you feel included or empowered
or that they're being heard
what is it about your government or your
nation that is allowing you to be so
nimble so entrepreneurial
here we like to think that we're the
best at everything
and
we're really behind in this stuff
and even in the commercial sector like
these metrics don't exist in the
commercial sector at all
is it just because you're a young nation
is it because you're
you have a majority young people is it
the entrepreneurial spirit like what is
it about the nation that is so
forward-thinking that you're doing so
much more than so many others
i'm so blown away by the fact that you
have these metrics the answer is simple
our leaders
listen they organize and they act
they listen to our people they listen to
science which is so important right now
science
and covet we listen to culture we
respond with the data they all give us
and and then
they take decisive organized action to
achieve it the uae model is one end
exclusion
bring inclusion
two end presumption assumption start
listening
three end being stuck in the past or
future rev up your moral imagination
which is the ability to accept reality
and the audacity kind of to hope for a
better future and you might say
hope i know you always talk about hope
it's something so
powerful our mars mission is called hope
and i'll tell you why because we believe
in the uae
how we hope determines how we live and
that's a central truth i'd love to hear
your thoughts on what is hope and i'll
tell you kind of our angle here
i think hope is like optimism it's the
undying belief in a bright future and no
matter how dark the tunnel you believe
that the future is bright i think that's
what hope is even if you have to squint
you see light at the end of the tunnel i
love this it's like
hope is the dream of something to come
at the confidence in something that will
be it's kind of this renewable resource
that if lost today it can be regained
tomorrow i love it we can plug into hope
when our supply kind of runs dry
and and everyone wants hope everyone
needs hope hope is essential for our
future without it i think we would not
believe in the possibility of a better
world let alone even have the motivation
to work toward it and i think you always
talk about motivation to do things it's
imperative to just know that one
ingredient that i believe is crucial to
hope is inclusion not just inclusion of
youth but everyone and it's worth noting
that you've normalized relations with
with israel which is a big step for the
entire region when that happened did you
have an opportunity to visit or have
some israelis visit with you well i
unfortunately didn't have an opportunity
to visit because of kovalev got in the
way of course yeah uh but it it's
amazing to see how
really this new movement
youth believe that the abrahamic accords
was the best decision because
we have
as young people the fresh opportunity to
define what kind of world we want to
live in
and we can choose the values with which
we want to shape the future
and what it means for israel emily as
two of the region's strongest nations
now becoming friends and partners is
that we have an opportunity to
demonstrate that peace is not merely a
ceasefire but a gateway to life and
nation and region exponentially greater
than when we were divided
to be honest the peace dividend that i
believe that came out of the abrahamic
reports is kind of this shared return on
investment of this peace deal
what we stand to gain by no longer
focusing on what divides us in this
region and particularly for youth i'm
not talking about the classical cold war
definition of peace dividend which
references cost avoidance or re
reallocation of less military spending
i'm talking about the magnitude simon of
social cultural economic even spiritual
benefits that come
from an agreement to move forward as
sons and daughters of abraham i want to
go back to listening that we were
talking about a minute ago a do you
consider yourself a good listener and
where did you learn listening you
yourself personally like
how did you learn to listen uh do i
consider i'm a good listener um
no i'm still learning it's a steep
learning curve but i i love
being better it's not simple when you
when you think about how you listen
matters so much it's about what happens
inside of your mind your heart your body
when you listen yeah and it's so
powerful
it's having the presence of mind to
notice what happened as a result of this
listening the second question is i i
learned about listening i've never even
thought about our presence except when i
first started this job and it was from
his highness the first sentence he even
told us uh when we started this new
strategy
was listen listen listen and i was like
why is this zionist telling us to listen
yeah and i realized wow
leadership is listening
leadership is all about listening
because when we listen we learn
and our assumptions about or the
barriers between one another are
dismantled i speak chinese and and the
character for listening in chinese is a
combination of the symbols for an ear i
heart and one how magical is that
ear
i heart and number one so if you put
them together simon the thing tells us
tells us this kind of word in chinese
tells us the choice to listen goes well
beyond your ears yeah
listen has to do with the heart fully
understanding what makes something
complete
in all that it's connected to
when you put the word maybe one which is
which is one of the meanings of the
characters is listening means to make
someone in someone's reality matter to
us to take him to heart and then to act
on it i took a listening class a few
years ago
it was offered to me and i thought sure
you know i'll do that and here's what i
learned i am an absolutely
fantastic
listener
when i'm talking to people that i will
probably never see again for the rest of
my life
but when i am talking to my closest
friends
and family
terrible
and when my close friends when we get in
a disagreement they say you don't listen
and i would say what are you talking
about listen i'm a pro at this i do this
for a living
and i realized though i had the skill
set i didn't apply it to the people i
loved and so my journey over the past
few years
has been really trying to learn to
listen not just as a skill set when i'm
helping somebody find their why you know
when i'm in in at work that that intense
concentration but being able to apply
that to my friends and my family
and the hardest part
is listening without judgment
but listening with curiosity
and especially because when it's
personal sometimes things that they say
i take personally and i i want to defend
myself or fight back to learn to put
those thoughts
aside so that they feel heard i'll get
my chance you know there's a there's a
big difference between listening and
waiting for your turn to speak
and job number one is i have to focus on
100 on them and and it's a journey it's
been a journey
what i'm fascinated by is how does a
nation do are there listening classes in
schools in the uae are you teaching the
youth how to listen actively no but i
would love to do that this is an an idea
i'm going to note down right now ah
imagine an entire generation of youth
with a skill set that older generations
could have they can all take the class
but that mandatory just like reading
uh writing and arithmetic
that every child learns to listen
imagine what they does for them and for
their lives and any kind of conflict
that they may experience for the rest of
their lives
that's profound
that is profound this is just
wow i think this we need to do a crash
course on the lost art of kind of
listening
none of us simon are good listeners all
the time it's it's human nature i get
distracted by what's going on
around me or i don't listen sometimes to
my son and i'm i'm on a work call or i'm
reading something and i think it takes
time and effort like reading
you pay attention to something uh some
things and sometimes you're skimming and
and and i feel like your ability to pay
attention focus the grades over time but
imagine if you start listening to
everyone as you just scan headlines or
or on a celebrity kind of a website or
instagram
you won't discover the
the wisdom the the the creativity uh the
energy in people and i i don't by the
way you are a good listener
every time i've sat with you since new
york and we've grabbed coffee you really
do
so we need you as a lecturer in our
course
well that's very kind thank you
what an honor um i i love the idea of
developing course work for kids to learn
to listen and to the best of my
knowledge and i haven't i haven't
scoured the world but
you know except for
individual cases in individual schools i
don't know where there's a school system
that's ever
included as part of the curriculum
i want to show you something that's very
powerful which is the arab food survey
that came out in 2020 and it's the 11th
consecutive year it's done by burst and
marsteller so it's not even done by
government but it's a true
voice for change um and it really maps
out for governments the importance of
engaging equipping and empowering youth
this survey keeps telling us again and
again
it repeats that young people in the arab
region want hope
and that hope is revealed begins with a
loss
in 2020 50
of our youth in that survey considered
leaving their countries for a better
life
40 percent want to leave their country
permanently simon driven by economic
reasons security education but what does
this data really mean what does it mean
when fifty percent of arab youth want to
leave their countries
it implies that they don't believe that
they have a voice
youth are telling us transparent and
cooperative leadership is the number one
issue for youth in the arab region they
want leaders that listen it's
unequivocally clear who's doing it right
is there another nation or a company or
an organization who's doing a good job
of fostering youth there's so many
nations to be honest that are doing
great i can't pinpoint one specific but
i think you're being generous i think
you're being politically correct because
from what i've seen most nations are
junk
at listening to youth
i'll be honest and
trust begins with honest conversation
right something like something that
we're doing right here
and to be honest simon who builds a home
better than the owner yeah who plants a
seed better than the loving gardener who
will tend it yeah who wants the horse
more than the jockey who's going to see
it to the finish line and who will
create their optimal future more than
the youth will inherit it so here's one
message i want to say for all
governments is please leave by the power
of inclusion because this is something
that we realized is so important in the
uae but i want to i want to ask you a
question
what i think about inclusion and
diversity because i really don't like
how diversity seems like a zero-sum game
um and i always have this conversation
with a lot of my friends even
in the states where they feel like okay
if you add someone who's of a different
color it means you're taking away jobs
from someone who's of another color
to me
that's okay that's their diversity item
but inclusion is beneficial to everyone
and it should be seen as a win-win nazi
or some so what's your take on that of
course i think to make diversity a
calculation to make it an equation
completely misses the point
diversity and inclusion requires effort
especially for those who
didn't grow up with it or weren't pushed
to do it we naturally are drawn to
people
who look like us sound like us
went to the place we went to school
because as you know tribal animals that
human beings are we're drawn to people
that are similar because we falsely
believe that there's security there and
it really it's based on values and the
more people we can attract to have a
different point of view
because if you all look the same and you
all came from the same education you all
came from the same place then your
opinions about it how to solve a problem
or seize an opportunity are going to be
very similar which means you're actually
creating weakness and liability and so
when you bring people who are from
different religions different sexual
orientations different gender identities
different upbringings different
schoolings you know somebody who grew up
rich versus somebody who grew up poor
what we're getting is an entirely
different perspective of how the world
works it's a little bit like the old
story of the the blind men uh and the
elephant and they're all asked to
describe you know the elephant and one
says well it's just all of this hair
that's all it is and the other one says
well no it's more like a tree trunk
that's what this is you only get a
picture of the elephant when you have
all the different points of view and
that's what diversity and inclusion
provides and i think any leader worth
their salt values that and any leader
that ignores it is it's to their own
peril quite frankly just because they're
creating weaker organizations to think
of it as zero sum is astonishing that
people still think that way i i love how
you double clicked on on the power of
inclusion
because
making someone feel more included simon
is not going to detract from anyone
else's experience which is the kind of
zero-sum game
equation to be honest you you started
this conversation talking about young
people and older age when you look at it
as a zero-sum game you'll see its youth
against adults or adults against you
it's not a degree in the uae it's more
this kind of let us create an inclusive
environment where everyone has an equal
chance to succeed including youth
and this is the kind of argument that we
need for youth around the world
to maybe double click more on on the
diversity we see it in a lot of
companies like hey let's hire more
diverse kind of candidates
but i feel like this is more misguided
because
diversity should be the result
of kind of people from different
backgrounds or different ages different
capabilities choosing to work for that
kind of company or
and and i remember um listening to a
podcast and they talked about i think
she's an author uh her name is verna
mears and she said diversity is being
invited to the party
but inclusion is being asked to death
so i hope you're dancing over there but
it's much easier to notice the
experiences of
exclusion but inclusion can be much more
invisible because it's not just
being invited on the table assignment
it's the actual authentic really genuine
involvement like being asked to dance
this is also very much into the work of
finite and infinite games you know a
finite mindset sees every interaction
as a win or a loss that if there's a
winner there's a loser if this person
wins by being included then that person
loses by being excluded and then setting
each thing up as a contest
a more infinite mindset sees the value
of bringing people in with shared values
as you said i want to work for this
company i want to work for this
organization i believe in their cause
i live my life by the same values that
this organization tries to operate by i
belong here and all the other stuff is
i'll find brothers and sisters here of
all shades and colors but we all have
one thing in common which is we're
driven by common cause and i think
that's a better way to create strong
culture which is we're driven by common
cause rather than we look the same or
sound the same or even if you have a
robust dei policy if there's no values
basis then you just have lots of people
who look different and sound different
but still don't get along we have to
care about the same things
your definition there's some people who
are thinking about it to zero sum i mean
that's nothing more than a finite game
in an infinite world which as
we know leads to problems of trust
cooperation and innovation so
i'm gonna change tax on you completely
which is you recently had
your second child right
yes and i want to know how becoming a
mother
has changed you i mean you you have this
remarkable life
when you became the minister of youth
you were the youngest government
minister in the world
the first road scholar from your country
you have all these remarkable things
that you've achieved and still so much
life ahead of you i want to know in face
of all of that how did you personally
change after you had a family um so yes
when i started my job i wasn't even
married um and right now i'm i'm
celebrating hope with the birth of my
daughter rova
it's my second child and
to be honest
i'm getting goosebumps talking about
this i'm biologically overcome by the
hope that having a child brings
motherhood might be the
chief hope
officer position um
simon it's uh it's remarkable
i realized that as a mother uh
i'm a learner but also a teacher and i
continue to learn from my children and
and i i feel like i'm becoming a better
teacher the two go hand in hand like
mother and child
it's amazing how it anchored my whole
life it gave me new perspectives
the more time i spend with my children
the more
i believe that
i feel like i'm developing radical
empathy in all aspects of my life even
at my work
it's powerful how
a lot of people always say oh my god
working mothers
and it's it's hard you can't balance and
you can't do well
uh in in either and i don't believe that
i don't think so it's a zero-sum game
again i don't think so it's black and
white
i think you begin to learn what
unconditional love is when you have a
family and that you can also pour that
love in the work that you do with the
people
um i used to have a wonderful experience
of working
and
now with my family i believe when i come
to work
i have a wonderful experience of living
i believe i'm more even productive i put
more hard work than i've done so i feel
like that misconception
needs to change especially with people
whenever they kind of see working
mothers i want to know what kind of
leader you were
before you had your first child
that changed
not because you had some hard feedback
not because something went wrong not
because you learned a lesson i want to
know what changed simply because you had
a child i learned what the word
dedication means
i think you were pretty dedicated before
you had a kid no but i mean dedicated
with your full heart and just maybe we
talked about listening having your eyes
and heart
and soul into one i feel like i learned
what it means really to be so dedicated
to every part of your life and the
importance of it i i learned what is
love
uh
it's very interesting because what is
love these are intangible right love is
intangible hope is intangible but let's
take the rose for instance if you look
at a rose is it possible for a rose to
say i'm gonna offer my fragrance to only
good people like simon and not good
people maybe like or badly like
shema or withhold it from bad people i
don't think so
um so
you begin to love everyone and
everything around you it's it's weird to
say this i know but it's like
you keep trying to be a better person
you can't discriminate
uh and i feel like the first quality of
love is is it's indiscriminate character
simon
uh it's it's like
the sun
um who makes kind of his sunshine on
good and bad a life right
and it's that's something that you learn
as a mother as a wife
uh it's powerful i'm still learning i'm
a student what a great analogy
i was told
recently
that having a child is the greatest
belief in the future if you're willing
to bring a child into this world it
means you believe in the hope and
optimism of the future
and what a standard even for the youth
of today
that we help empower them to build a
world that they want to bring more
children into this world
that they believe that this world will
be great for their children i love this
because it's also about how do you
instill in young people the values that
you want to see
the future uh uh values of of citizens
and i think
how can you if you if our nation was
built on trust and respect and peaceful
resistance how do you ensure that these
young people have that i think this is
the hard part it's it's invisible when
you look at a tree
the tree is not dragging
me under it
to sit under it's straight it's there
it's it's spreading out love somehow
and and that's what you learn as a
mother you just wanna you love her and
to be honest i started i love
my colleagues kids even i feel like
they're my kids
i want to take care of them just it's
it's something
that should be felt and and it can't be
seen here's what i've learned in talking
to you
all these magical things that you're
doing for youth with youth
listening
you know inclusion
a voice
i wonder if what it all boils down to is
that what you're actually teaching young
people to do is to love
and if you can teach an entire
generation to love
in a deeper way than previous
generations
then that and that alone
is what makes the future bright
oh wow and and how how long does this
kind of love last and then i
feel like there's no there's no such
thing as deficient love or partial love
it's in its fullness and imagine if you
have that kind of love
for
your
community your nation uh the world and
everyone around you what kind of person
will that young person be oh this is
wonderful
my cheeks hurt from smiling
this whole time i'm just so inspired by
i mean no
single department of government
can be said to be building the future
you know infrastructure labor you know
housing
no one is building the future more
than a ministry of youth
and i hope that the work that you do
and you're doing
serves as an inspiration to other
governments who equally want to build a
bright future that they have to have a
ministry of youth because it's
ostensibly a ministry of the future
that's what it is
thank you for taking the time i really
appreciate it i just want to
maybe one thing
the most meaningful part of my job is
when i see
an initiative or policy empower another
young person
it's like seeing a bird take flight
i remember reading that if birds don't
have the proper bone simon in place in
and around their wings these birds can't
fly and they can't even take off
that's such a delicate mystery how a
bird is designed
to me
a young person unequipped to live a life
to their potential
is like seeing a bird unable to fly
simon it's unnatural it's not how youth
are designed
going back to why it's so important and
i'm grateful that we have a leadership
that believes it's a government's job to
create the conditions that will enable
all young people with different
abilities different aspirations to
develop their ways and take flight and i
have a deep sense of responsibility
simon to co-create the conditions for
all youth to fly
it's it's deeply satisfying to wake up
and go to work with great people and see
youth-centric policies and programs come
out of our team's hard work
that's the heartbeat of our ministry and
it's a gift
i'm so grateful it's so wonderful thank
you so much
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other
you